el programa de la sección en español del
radio
y entonces como no me escucharon bien
voy a cargar un poquito más alto porque
el técnico me dice que no está bien la
voz si nos encontramos aquí en el
estudio pues con visita este día para
este castor mensajero castor cibernético
canadá en la radio interna
estamos en el estudio 26 muchas gracias
por traer nosotros podemos hacer así
pero no no
hola buenos días que estamos somos los
invitados que queremos
vamos a decirlo
santiago tabanera gracias por invitarnos
desayuné un vehículo huevito y una
malteada sí aquí estamos con un poco
apretados pero con mucho gusto hasta
mañana
calor humano sí
[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos una vez más a
canadá en las américas café
visión semanal que les ofrecemos el
servicio en español de radio canadá
internacional hoy con un poquito de
demora por una leve de problema técnico
pero por sorpresa estamos una vez más en
este reencuentro que les proponemos cada
siete días desde la sección en español
de radio canadá internacional hoy con un
estudio nutrido y la demora justamente
la tenemos ahora pero la vamos a llenar
con todos nuestros invitados a correr el
tiempo para que cada uno pueda hablar
como verán ustedes ahí en la imagen está
más poblado que nunca este estudio iba a
estar más poblado aún un poquito más
tarde cuando se reintegre paloma que va
a estar un poco demorada también por el
momento estamos aquí pablo gomes barrios
ahora qué tal saludos a todos
leonardo gimeno que tal buenas noches
buenos días buenas tardes mi nombre es
luis laborda y como ustedes pueden ver
tenemos nada más y nada menos que tres
invitados a falta de uno
o dos que es lo que tenemos
habitualmente en esta ocasión contamos
con la presencia de marisa rosales argón
za que está allí en la punta con
santiago tavera y con beatriz herrera
esos tres están relacionados con una
exposición artística que comienza hoy no
es cierto se inaugura hoy oficialmente
en el marco del festival latín arte
marisa es la curadora de esta exposición
y tanto santiago como beatriz son dos de
los artistas que participan con ellos
vamos a hablar entonces a lo largo de
esta emisión para conocer un poco de
este evento que durante cuando marisol
hasta el 29 de marzo se puede visitar la
exposición pero bueno ya platicaremos de
la obra de todos y la podrán visitar
también por su sitio web y en el sitio
web de latín arte perfecto muy bien y
antes de comenzar entonces a dialogar
con nuestros invitados como hacemos
habitualmente partimos con un tema
principal tienen que educación tiene que
ver con la celebración del año nuevo
chino que comienza el 25
en enero es decir mañana para nosotros
para los habitantes de asia
específicamente para china que eso será
antes por una cuestión de diferencias
horarias en un ratito nada más esa
celebración que atrae la atención de
miles de millones diríamos de personas
en asia
e incluso en china pero que este año se
va a ver un poco trastocado y esas otras
tocada esa celebración por el brote de
coronavirus que está afectando a ese
país asiático y que ha llevado a las
autoridades chinas a incluso cerrar por
completo una ciudad en una lengua
diferente cuando uno habla de 40
millones decía bueno son 40 mil de
personas
hay países que tienen muchísimo menos
que eso o sea hay países enteros que son
mucho menos que esta ciudad que ha sido
cerrada para evitar la propagación de
coronavirus y señores esa celebración
del año nuevo chino que entonces
moviliza a los habitantes de ese país de
un punto al otro de ese territorio
inmenso gente que se traslada de una
ciudad a la otra para reunirse con sus
seres queridos y que en esta ocasión va
a tener que limitar sus desplazamientos
porque las propias autoridades chinas
han solicitado evitar las aglomeraciones
y el contacto con grupos masivos de
gente de manera tal de reducir los
riesgos de un contagio mayor al que se
ha producido hasta este momento que ya
ha provocado más de 20 muertos si le
digamos antes de salir 26 25 muertos y
800 casos confirmados bueno ya está
también en norteamérica
se temía en un principio y bueno pues ya
hubo alguien que llegó justamente creo
que de la provincia de wuhan donde
y salió este coronavirus y pero viajó
antes que es comenzará a correr la
noticia y bueno de viajar en hacer
manifestar a la persona también porque
evidentemente llegó y fue internado
después de haber llegado
tiempo después dos o tres días después
así que efectivamente y además ese caso
también provocó alerta por no decir
alarma en las autoridades sanitarias de
columbia británica ya que ese caso desde
el estado de washington en eeuu que
linda con el sur de columbia británica
así que las autoridades sanitarias de
esa provincia del oeste canadiense
también han implementado medidas para
prevenir un posible contagio para tomar
las acciones que sean necesarias ante un
eventual brote de la enfermedad también
aquí entrará hasta el momento nada de
eso ha ocurrido hacer decía casos
sospechosos y lo que ven pero serios
descartados así que por el momento no
hay nada que temer por lo menos en lo
que hace al territorio igual digamos que
la temperatura en quebec no acompaña
porque estamos hace los días hacían 35
bajo cero
hicieron 2 sobre 0 y eso es cambio
temperatura la gente se de sabri a esa
forma evidentemente
probablemente el problema es que uno se
descuida uno se enferma y bueno
obviamente cualquier cosa que tenga
todos temperatura es posible caso de
coronavirus porque es el inédito que
tenemos todos los sospechosos ahora en
esta ocasión el año nuevo chino implica
además una celebración especial porque
también del inicio de una nueva década y
como sabemos el calendario chino seguía
sobre todo a partir de figuras de
animales en este caso el año corresponde
al año de la rata de metal
yo soy rata y todavía estoy investigando
cuál es la parte que tengo de mecánica
exacto me gusta metálica pero no tiene
que ver no ha sufrido ninguna fractura
en la cadera
un sobrino que tuvo una plaqueta en la
pierna en el fémur yo todavía nada bueno
pero vamos a incluir a nuestros
invitados en la conversación sobre el
horóscopo chino y en todo caso mi
pregunta es lo hablábamos más temprano
con pablo ustedes creen en el horóscopo
creen en esas predicciones que en muchas
partes del mundo en distintos países
ganan o tienen mejor dicho desde siempre
adeptos pero por miles y miles y miles
gente que sigue fielmente el horóscopo
que lo lee y hay gente que dice que es
el libro de los horrores varios altos
precios del ojo personalmente no creo
que el destino lo va haciendo cargo y si
por ejemplo ídolos como chino en esta
ocasión la organza de metal que predice
que este va a ser tu año del año en el
que vas a ganar mucho dinero te vas a
hacer famosa vas a conocer distintos
países vas a poder viajar la aventura
pero va a sobrar a lo largo de estos 365
días que tiene el año librerías yo creo
que como todo cerebro humano trata de
apegarse al predicciones positivas y
creo que hay una reacción humana que
tiene que ver con eso personalmente
cuando la razón viene creo que creo que
no pues sin saberlo de una tecla porque
precisamente los retos de meta la
característica principal de historia
elemental es el de la actitud positiva
he comenzado con
oye tú acaso crees en él yo creo que un
poco me gusta chequearlo de vez en
cuando no es que lo sigan y que en
verdad como que lo sienta fielmente que
si dicen algo pero de vez en cuando si
me gustado siento que somos tan pequeños
en este mundo que es algo de energías de
los planetas de del espacio seguro
tienen que afectar lo algo loco pero que
nos afectan
la exposición de la luna con las mareas
es absolutamente y estos algunos hablan
de esas cosas no los planetas la luna
está ya que evidentemente
no hay nada científico que lo compruebe
que la historia de ese martes cruza
enfrente de plutón y yo estoy hacia el
vertical me voy a caer no sé pero uno
siempre deja una partida abierta y para
dos
como este es el año rápido si verdad
está y me dijeron vas a tener un
excelente año entonces
beatriz cuál es su posición
[Música]
yo creo que como seres humanos tenemos
un talento innato en encontrar
significado en todos los números el
clima la posición de los planetas las
mareas lo vamos a encontrar si lo
buscamos
y yo por muchos años miraba en los
horóscopos soy un buen muy muy leal muy
trabajadora miran los horóscopos porque
era como cuando no estaba un poco
atascado en la mañana era como que el
plan del día y después me olvidaba
totalmente no es que sabía que era y
revelante no tiene nada que ver con nada
pero como quiera como
la mención al sistema
ha dicho y el caso pablo no no creo para
nada en los horóscopos ni el uno ni el
otro yo sé que soy sagitario pero cuál
es el ascendiente y el siguiente
[Música]
pero por el resto no sé nada es más ni
siquiera conozco mi horóscopo chino ni
siquiera sé si en el mes de diciembre
el año nacional 2008 y tiene que ver con
no sé cuántos años pasan y empiezan los
animales de nuevo y donaciones 72 y los
12 años sensación 12 pero bueno lo
cierto es que gracias al brote de
coronavirus las autoridades chinas han
decidido que numerosas de las
actividades que ya estaban previstas y
preparadas y quienes hayan visto
imágenes alguna vez saben que son
eventos que requieren meses y meses de
preparación en cuanto a la escenografía
en cuanto al vestuario
etcétera mentalmente todo ese esfuerzo
este año va a verse un poco opacado
porque varios de esos eventos van a
tener que ser suspendidos pero se
entiende que es por una cuestión de
interés general y común preservar la
salud de la población china uno no
quisiera sospechar lo que puede llegar a
ocurrir si estábamos discutiendo el
pablo si eran si son 1.200 o 1.300 son
1500 millones de chinos sea como sea es
mucha gente con que una aunque un
porcentaje de esa población se contagie
de un brote una enfermedad tan
complicada como es el coronavirus eso
sería una catástrofe así que suspender
por lo menos por este año alguno de los
festejos del año nuevo creo que en el
fondo va a servir para preservar la
tranquilidad no solamente de la
población en china sino de toda asia en
general y del mundo entero en particular
que nos preguntaste es a nosotros pero
tú pones tu posición frente al horóscopo
los orozco soy un descreído total
[Risas]
a pesar de que como periodista y como
encargado de la emisión de algún canal
en mi argentina natal en algún momento
tuve que estar encargado de que saliera
al aire porque como te comentaba hoy en
ese canal en el que yo trabajaba en su
momento y que la gente seguía
masivamente cuando se producía una leve
demora ya sea durante demoraba segundos
en salir al aire con el horóscopo o con
la lotería la gente llamaba por teléfono
a la redacción que yo no sé dónde
sacaban el teléfono de la redacción cuál
es el problema tengo el horóscopo no
puedo sería trabajar con reclamos muy
vigorosos por no decir directamente
qué pasa con respecto al coronavirus por
la realidad que es una enfermedad tipo
una gripe o no es bueno mil coronas es
un virus que se llama de esa manera
porque está
envuelto en una capa que le otorga el
aspecto de corona cuando es observado
bajo el microscopio eléctrico y lo que
hace es produce síntomas que son
parecidos al de una gripe de hecho
participa en la gripe común pero es como
no existe el tratamiento contra la
variedad del virus que es el coronavirus
en particular
esta enfermedad puede producir o puede
conllevar algunas complicaciones por
ejemplo puede tener que ver con el
entrenamiento de la neumonía
entonces quiere afecta al había
respirado exactamente y si bien no hay
un tratamiento específico para el
coronavirus si los médicos pueden dar
consejos y medicación que reduzca los
síntomas y el malestar que hay enfermo
la corona vieron que se enfermaron y que
salieron ilesos y todo el que se enferma
y de que el único tratamiento que
existen en realidad es el del tiempo que
pase por sí solo y tiene que ver
entonces con las defensas de la persona
tiene decenas las personas muchos amigos
de salud general
si hay tendencia enfermedades de ese
tipo se puede complicar como decíamos
en realidad entonces hay que tener
cuidado con las bases del cuidado con la
gente que tiene gripe o sea los los
factores de riesgo son la edad por
ejemplo a los ancianos y los niños si
uno está enfermo de diabetes y no está
en forma el corazón es en forma los
pulmones ese tipo de cosas son las que
tenemos más en cuenta en el momento de
tener cuidado en realidad efectivamente
bustillos además unai emery a mí me
encantan las fm de no sé por qué pero
tengo no le creo el horóscopo mucho
listo y me encantan las efemérides vamos
a empezar por el 19 pase que empecé y
después me mezclé así que voy a dar
vuelta por viejita el 19 de enero es el
día mundial de la nieve que se lo
pasamos de largo
tuvimos nieve para ser dulces así que
íbamos a tener mucha más no termina aquí
esto para los que vivimos en la
provincia de québec en gran parte de
canadá
con los vídeos de ellos creo que tampoco
festejaron el día mundial de la nieve el
21 es el día internacional del abrazo 21
de enero hoy es 24 ya no nos abrazamos
pero lo festejamos también
el 23 de enero el muermo de dalí el 24
es el día internacional de la educación
hoy hoy es el día de la educación y el
día de la cultura africana y
afrodescendiente así que todos ellos un
abrazo grande y
el 25 el año chino el 25 de enero y hoy
se cumplen 75 años de la liberación de
auschwitz que bueno tal como es a esa
fecha dice y ese evento específico da
como inicio a la conmemoración del día
internacional de
víctimas del holocausto así que esas son
nuestras medidas para el 10 para esta
semana bueno y vamos a dar entonces ya
cabida a nuestros invitados para hablar
del tema específico por el que les hemos
citado hoy aquí que es la participación
de ellos en el festival latín arte en la
edición de este año el festival al final
que por qué se hace de hace mucho tiempo
ya entonces quería para comenzar
preguntarle a marisa que es la curadora
de esta exposición que de qué trata esta
edición del festival latina de marisa y
qué es lo que vamos a poder ver allí si
hay que decir que si tradicionalmente el
festival latinarte se lleva a cabo el
mes de septiembre y octubre ahora
estamos hablando de una exposición que
sale un poquito de ese marco y si bien
es organizado por latin arte es
subvencionado financiado por el gobierno
de la ciudad de montreal el consejo de
artes de montreal y sale un poco en el
marco del festival propiamente y es una
exposición una exposición que reagrupa 3
estas que son de origen latinoamericano
y que yo tiendo a nombrar latino
quebequenses porque viven en las
provincias y que han creado o se han
formado acá desde hace tiempo y son tres
artistas que vienen de orígenes
completamente distintos beatriz herrera
que viene de chile federico carvajal que
viene de méxico que no que no puede
estar con nosotros y santiago que
santiago tavera que me medí colombia la
idea general de la exposición es que los
tres artistas con orígenes tan distintos
y historias de vida y prácticas
diferentes se coinciden por eso el
nombre de la exposición que se llama
pasajes convergentes o pasar su
conversión es la idea de que todas estas
trayectorias de alguna manera coinciden
hay puntos de encuentro que pasan por
temas y reflexiones que tienen que ver
con la tecnología con la idea de la
inmersión
la idea evidentemente del uso del arte
como un sistema complejo para entender
el mundo también entonces la idea de
base cesa y se exploran en diferentes
medios como en la instalación numérica
la escultura electrónica el dibujo y
también la escultura propiamente ahí el
vídeo también hay una serie de
coincidencias que pasan por los
materiales por las reflexiones y que
también hacen una reflexión sobre él
sobre el ambiente y tú los nombradas
marisa uno de los realizadas que
participa es santiago tavera que está
aquí es creciente con nosotros también
santiago en el caso tú yo
específicamente qué es lo que verá al
público que asista a esta muestra bueno
en esta obra que abrió anoche iba a
estar en exhibida por un mes estoy
presentando una obra inmersiva de vídeo
interactiva también donde crea un
espacio amarillo con filtros amarillos
con superficies que reflejan
vídeos y luces entonces en eso tengo el
público entra al espacio queda
completamente inmersivo en este en este
mundo que cree más amarillo donde pueden
jugar con un captan y pueden mover una
imagen que es una galaxia de casas
flotantes no sé si te dieran el toque
sus niños también
sí sí sí esto fue de la noche avanzar en
el tema el tema de la exhibición hay que
vive en esa pieza donde la gente entra y
mueve muere esta galaxia estas casas
flotantes y ahí en ellas pueden
encontrar historias en francés en inglés
y en español donde cuenta un poquito
esta experiencia del cuerpo en un estado
de translación de traducción de
traslación y de desplazamiento entonces
con eso la idea es poner a una audiencia
en un mundo medio físico pero también
digital y que tengan esta experiencia de
traducción virtual temas está decir
entonces que tu propuesta como artista
está bien lejos de la de concebir a la
obra de arte como algo que el público
solamente debe contemplar
hay más hay más aquí hay muchos
elementos en los que no sólo desde
pararse a ver a contemplar como dices
pero también es interactuar de pensar en
la presencia que no tiene uno como
habita un espacio no como interactúa con
otra gente en un espacio y por eso pongo
filtros de percepción que alteran un
poco como como entendemos los materiales
físicos y digitales cuando estábamos
afuera conversamos de esto no va a ser
expuesto en un solo lugar va a moverse
en tres lugares diferentes en entendí
y que está cuando uno monta nuevamente
saliendo de un espacio físico y entrando
a otro
donde se va a presentar la muestra
cambia la muestra porque cambia qué es
lo que cambia
en mí en mi caso mi trabajo s
la idea es intervenir un espacio de
meterle luces y sonidos y colores estoy
yo creo que mi trabajo la verdad depende
mucho en los espacios
la arquitectura de los espacios donde
muestro eso entonces en sí cada vez que
la muestro
así sea este trabajo otros la verdad se
adapta y vuelve y se vuelve una pieza
diferente es interesante que se pueden
ir a las dos muestras y puede uno
valorar el cambio que se está realizando
debido al emplazamiento físico antes
dado el paso a beatriz se quería cerrar
el diálogo con marisa porque sé que se
tiene que ir
marisa cuando hablamos de curar una obra
de que esto no sobra si el concepto de
curar es muy problemático porque bueno
curar que quien está enfermo no yo yo lo
pondría más como un trabajo que hace una
selección un trabajo que trata de
entender un poco qué es lo que está
ocurriendo en el ambiente en el tiempo
en un espacio específico qué arte se
produce y a partir de eso
hacer conexiones yo también lo vería
como una metáfora del chef que hace una
ensalada que para que sea nutritiva rica
agradable a la vista también tiene que
buscar los elementos precisos las dosis
exactas para
y ofrecernos un
un platillo que no satisfaga y que
también sea nutritivo entonces un poco
yo lo veo así
esta idea de ir a buscar y meter en
relación a mí me da gracias porque en
cierta ciudad
yo vivía en santiago del estero en
argentina y en santiago del estero
curado
[Música]
que emborracha borracho y simboliza
muchas gracias sabemos de tres
deportistas verdes como tu presencia
aquí mucha suerte con esta edición de
latín arte en el 2020 y esperamos tener
que nuevamente no dentro de mucho tiempo
pues muchas gracias por la invitación y
esperemos que pasen a ver la exposición
y a los que no puedan estar en montreal
hay que decir recordar dónde estás en la
casa de la cultura de
no tratante gas es muy cerca del metro
del maguey y para que la gente que está
en montreal pero para que no esté en
montreal y quiera conocer al trabajo de
los artistas y este proyecto necesitó de
latín arte va a haber un vídeo y pueden
entrar a ver también los hechos de los
artistas van a descubrir un universo
infinito y va a ser lindo si lees la
presentación que vamos a poner en línea
en un ratito más en nuestro sitio
integral pero asia apariciones
mientras tanto o marisa hacer retirar
con mucho mucho mucho cuidado y meter a
éste ha tenido le damos entonces la
palabra a beatriz herrera que es la otra
artista que participa en esta edición
beatriz que es lo que va a ver el
público de tu obra en esta edición de
latina en la que van a ver cuando
entraran las galerías a mí tres bestias
en realidad es
tengo tres objetos esculturales y un
dibujo largo aunque uno de los objetos
también es un dibujo que si cerrar al
ser un objeto pero para mí lo que hago
lo que trato de hacer para la gente que
he llegado a un espacio es como una
ecología de esculturas que tienen
relaciones unas con otras que van a
decir como un coro uso montones de
materiales que son reciclados trabajo
mucho con tecnología pero también con
supongo lo que se diría podría decir
escultura más clásica en el sentido de
que es material
en esta serie de todos los materiales
que use para crear las obras de gran
cosas que encontré en la calle o que me
regalaron
o que alguien me pasó pero como tengo mi
taller o en un tremendo edificio lleno
de gente trabajando no eran cosas
típicas alguien me paso un saco
gigantesco de cuero fantástico otra
persona me paso un cable de los que
eléctricos que meten bajo tierra
tengo montones de motores encontrados
así que la idea era tratar de crear como
unas cosas fantásticas que hicieran
ruidos con vibraciones tienen pequeños
motores que vibran y que hacen como un
pequeño resorte dentro de cada obra así
que van a ver unas veces grandes
colgadas del techo y van a escuchar
las cosas que van y ahí eso ahora tiene
dos son dos artistas jóvenes nacidos en
el extranjero pero que reciben aquí
habían comenzamos su actividad artística
en sus países de nacimiento o se
lanzaron una vida artística ya estando
aquí en canadá
yo llegué toda mi familia a ontario y yo
tenía 12 años
entonces me acuerdo de tomar clases de
pintura y cosas así en colombia pero ya
las carreras pues comienza acá en canadá
me fui me formé en el arte acá en de
pregrado hice de psicología bellas artes
y ya en montreal hice la maestría en
arte también y entonces siendo que tuvo
carreras inició como artista aquí en
canadá de qué manera se encuentra
presente colombia si es que está
presente si también me gusta mucho
volver a con lo que trabajar allá con
diferentes estoy colaborando con
colombianos allá ha ido mucho al
festival de la imagen en manizales en
colombia donde he ido a hacer una serie
de talleres también como experimentales
con la tecnología con cámaras de 360 de
realidad virtual y también he ido a
exhibir trabajo ahí con una colaboración
que tengo con otra colombiana que se
llama laura costa con la que ahorita
estoy trabajando y tenemos otra
exhibición en un par de semanas aquí en
montreal también
si no tenía una pregunta para el día 3
porque en la información que tenemos acá
dice que te gustan los robots pero como
que te atrae
en tu formación que tuviste primero como
artista y segundo como llegó
no tengo ninguna formación en absoluto
por el principio yo la primera educación
primero que yo venía de la familia de
científicos así que no tuve permiso
estudiar arte ningún momento hasta que
terminé y ya lo primero que hice fue un
aprendizaje súper intenso anuncia la
universidad en cerámica
llegué a un momento en la vida que me di
cuenta que uno no tiene idea cómo
funciona nada en el mundo de tecnología
y tenemos la idea especialmente con los
niños ahora que saben apretar el botón y
jugar con juegos vídeos y que entienden
cómo funciona algo no uno aprende cómo
apretar un botón no prende la mamá y
pensé una persona adulta ignorante puede
aprender cómo funciona el mundo y el
mundo de tecnología qué pasa cuando se
prende un enchufe
cuando uno hace andar un auto o es muy
tarde así que empecé primero que nada a
estudiar todo lo que tenía que ver con
electricidad con comunicación pero sola
y llegué a un momento de desesperación
que ya o que no entiendo hay un vine a
montreal a hacer una maestría y en
escultura pero tuve acceso equipo
y la tecnicidad que me pudieran enseñar
algunas cosas y amigos que me fascinaba
de los robots es que son todo un mito es
un juego viene del cine viene de las
películas son nuestra pesadilla pero es
un es algo físico de nuevo no es como
los robots que controlan por ejemplo los
algoritmos que manejan las inversiones
de la bolsa económica es algo que
literalmente podemos tocar y podemos ver
que es muy distinto que todos los
sistemas que controlan la realidad ahora
así que para mí era una manera de
meterme en algo que era físico y ver si
lo podía armar y lo podía hacer
funcionar y por supuesto cuando llegue
al momento que podía hacerlo funcionar
empecé a perder el interés que esto no
es tan interesante como lo que como es
un tipo de tecnología como hay
demasiados artistas que pretenden ser
ingenieros ahora y tienen miles de
dólares para contratar gente que les
arme las cosas yo no tengo ningún
interés en hacer esto
y aunque esta exposición está comenzando
a durar hasta marzo con marzo se tiene
ya en mente en carpeta en proceso tal
vez alguna un proyecto artístico futuro
absolutamente ser es decir primero sigue
ahorita como estaba mencionando tengo la
exhibición una colaboración con una
amiga que abre el 8 de febrero en mayo
en un centro intercultural también que
promueve mucho la danza el teatro y las
artes visuales entonces también hemos
creado otro mundo inmersivo con
performance con videos en vivo luces y
eso ahorita lo que estoy lo que estoy
trabajando y también pues varios
proyectos así que que van saliendo
durante el año que yo
y para vivir pensando otra obsesión
después de abandonar la roca me di
cuenta con este proyecto que la parte
estética física de belleza me encantó
cómo salió pero la idea de crear una
relación tecnológica
entre los objetos no lo que han sido en
un fracaso total así que estoy empezando
una investigación en sistemas de
ecología con el tema de cómo usamos lo
material en el mundo porque es algo que
ya había empezado a tratar de hacer
usando restos de materiales pero esto
estoy empezando un proyecto colaborativo
con investigadores investigadores en
ciencias sociales y en biología para
estudiar cómo crear una ecología para de
parásitos entre objetos esculturales
mecánicos y robóticos y jardines
queremos crear como una ecología
viviente con plantitas específicamente
con musgos que crecen solamente en los
en el polo sur y el polo norte y en
ninguna otra parte del mundo y queremos
ver cuáles son las relaciones entre las
plantas la tierra los hongos y cómo
tratar de recrear eso como un sistema
mecánico
todo esto casi un año pero me doy cuenta
cuando montamos esta exhibición que las
ideas y las formas básicas que me están
empujando ya están ahí pero por supuesto
trabajar con algo viviente
pues muy bien el tiempo corre tenemos
algún mensaje y tenemos mensajes en este
caso es javier gonzález garay que dice
el contra virus está el coronavirus
contra virus está corriendo por todas
partes cordeles de 3 para todos del
equipo de canadá en las américas es café
y también para los invitados y gustavo
lucas otro nuestros top fun saludos
desde la ciudad de melo en ser largo
uruguay feliz año nuevo chino saludos a
los invitados la gente que nos ve en
nuestra transmisión de facebook polo
aquí tengo un mensaje de carlos me cante
con respecto a un tema granjero
canadiense regala su tierra a una
condición él dice soy de colombia soy
médico veterinario de la universidad de
bogotá
además soy administrador de fincas del
sena
tengo tengo experiencia en granjas
autosuficientes donde trabajo en el
bienestar para los animales y el respeto
por la vida de todos los seres vivos
además he trabajado en eeuu en granjas
de vacas lecheras y de ganado test en
cortes es el mensaje de carlos mica esos
son entonces algunos los mensajes que
nuestros oyentes nos hace llegar
continuamente yo tengo por aquí un
mensaje de reyna morejón que dice
o está referido al tema ottawa anuncia
medidas especiales migratorias para
venezolanos y dice mi pasaporte
venezolano está vencido desde mayo de
necesito renovarlo o extender su validez
para viajar a venezuela
el consulado que me corresponde es el de
vancouver pero está cerrado cómo puedo
hacer o dónde puedo acudir para la
prórroga
en realidad no sé a dónde acudir supongo
que a un consulado es lo más probable
pero lo que nos dice es que con el
pasaporte vencido se puede viajar y ya
que se podría viajar por el mundo con su
pasaporte vencido hasta llegar a un
lugar que tenga la posibilidad de hacer
los trámites para la renovación si de
hecho el pasaporte está vencido pero el
pasaporte como tal caduca cuando llegas
al país de origen al origen entonces ahí
las autoridades retienen el documento
porque ya está vencido pero hasta ese
momento es el único documento con el
columpio viajar puede dejar con el
documento ya no es que antes 15 años
viajando por el mundo con el monumento
vencido pero practicar el lugar o un
lugar donde se pueda hacer se puede se
puede ser bueno muy bien
vamos a pasar a los temas que hemos
estado trabajando durante esta semana
aquí en la sección antes de proseguir
brevemente con el diálogo con nuestros
invitados
propongo entonces que ustedes se enteren
de que lo que hemos estado trabajando y
conocemos actualmente cada uno de
nosotros va a presentar una sugerencia
quieres comenzar todo llegué un poco
tarde para que estoy si luís pues yo
quiero presentarles hoy un reportaje que
hice esta semana a partir de documentos
que obtuvo un periodista de la canadian
broadcasting corporation de la que es
parte radio canadá internacional en
vancouver
jason productor obtuvo documentos de los
servicios fronterizos estadounidenses en
los que se habla de la del arresto por
tráfico de personas de un residente
canadiense de origen mexicano ciudadano
mexicano que estaba pasando gente
pasando mexicanos a partir de canadá
hacia eeuu entonces en la investigación
que logró hacer el periodista y también
obtuvimos copia de los documentos de la
corte de montana del instituto del
estado de montaña
se ven los nombres de las personas y el
hecho de particular de que se detuvo al
grupo de diez mexicanos en los que iban
incluidos dos niños por en este caso
particular de tráfico de personas y lo
que mencioné en los reportajes que hay
una diferencia entre tráfico de personas
y trata de personas
recordemos que el tráfico de personas es
cuando una persona paga por pasar a una
frontera y regularmente sin pasar por
los servicios fronterizos del país que
lo recibiría ese es el tráfico de
personas en este caso las personas
habrían pagado dos mil dólares al
comenzar el proceso al entrar a canadá y
después a atravesar la frontera
estadounidenses eeuu y tendrían que
haber pagado 11 mil 500 dólares más a
esta misma persona entonces bueno les
presento toda la investigación en
nuestro sitio de internet si buscan
residente canadiense tráfico de personas
han encontrado perfecto entonces
publicado paulo en tu caso por ese tema
que sugerir a los oyentes y julio muy
rápidamente es el caso de un profesor de
la universidad mcgill
que llevaba 18 años enseñando en esta
universidad y en renunció renunció
después de todo este tiempo de trabajar
en la universidad porque él le pidió
tres veces a las autoridades
universitarias de macri a que retiraran
sus inversiones en la industria de los
combustibles e inversiones que son
bastante importantes hay que decir que
michael tiene 1.700 millones de dólares
invertidos en en su fondo de inversión
de los cuales 8.7 por ciento está en
estos en el petróleo y carburantes
entonces la universidad se negó a
retirar su inversión de ese campo y eso
fue lo que provocó la renuncia de este
profesor hay otras universidades que ya
se han retirado de ese mercado entre
ellas podemos mencionar muy rápidamente
la universidad de british columbia la
universidad de ottawa laval de quebec
universo
de qué mostrar y la universidad
concordia no perfecto muy bien pagado
gracias a la mía simple yo simple el
corto si a todos con éstos relojito se
firman convenios firmó convenios esta
semana para
lograr que la gente tenga como
recompensas por hacer ejercicio antes la
recompensa es mirar y decir
corrida con rita ahora la recompensa
puede ser monetaria puede ser con un
reloj a pagar mientras estoy haciendo
ejercicio hay otra hay un convenio con
la uah jams y en ese caso el convenio
implica que puedo hacer ejercicios para
pagar
en un curso específico para gente que no
tiene para pagar o sea hacer el trabajo
social digamos hacer ejercicio para que
el agua no se acepte
número x de niños para hacer cursos de
natación por ejemplo entonces suena
bastante interesante suena lindo hay que
leer la nota para ver cómo funciona pues
perfecto yo por mi lado les sugiero un
artículo que tiene que ver hablábamos la
semana pasada de hambre en canadá en
esta semana no hablamos de hambre
específicamente sino de alimentación
sana hay una iniciativa del organismo de
quitar que todos conocen lo que mucha
gente conoce que propicia que los
estudiantes de las escuelas tanto
públicas como privadas de el país
adquieran los hábitos de alimentación
sana produciendo ellos mismos sus
propios alimentos o favoreciendo en todo
caso la producción de alimentos de
manera local
entonces incluir más vegetales más
frutas una comida más balanceada en la
dieta de los estudiantes y no solamente
la comida chatarra la comida rápida que
suele ser la que consumen como credit
that by entonces proyectos o
financiamiento disponibles para quienes
presenten propuestas está abierta la
inscripción el plazo límite es hasta el
27 de marzo de este año quienes estén
interesados pueden ir al sitio de
internet de quiter o entrar a nuestro
sitio internet leer este artículo
allí van a encontrar el link y puede
entonces llenar los dos formularios que
hay que completar para poderse ser
beneficiado de una gran bolsa de uno de
los financiamientos que pone disposición
es quitar que es por un monto total de
10 mil dólares
bueno muchas gracias entonces un mensaje
hemos llegado un pequeño saludo el smile
zamora nos está viendo y nos saluda
desde méxico muchísimas gracias a él les
agradecemos a nuestros invitados
entonces una vez más la presencia
santiago tavera muchísimas gracias por
estar con nosotros
lo mismo le decimos a beatriz herrera
marisa que ya ha tenido que partir y a
ustedes por supuesto por seguirnos como
cada semana a través de este encuentro
que ya es una costumbre para nosotros se
cuenten es que los saludamos entonces a
la próxima ocasión
y si la próxima
[Música]